Ukraine's president is accusing Russia
of planting explosives at the zaparizian
nuclear power plant Moscow in turn has
said Kiev is planning to attack the
facility Russia took over what is
Europe's largest nuclear facility in the
days after the invasion of Ukraine last
year since then each side has regularly
accused the other of shelling near the
plant and risking a nuclear disaster
twice
we have information from our
intelligence that on the roof of several
power units of the zabarucho nuclear
power plant the Russian military insult
objects similar to explosives perhaps to
simulate the hit on the plane maybe they
have some other scenarios
in a moment we'll go live to Yulia
shapovalova in Moscow but first let's
get the latest from Rob McBride in Kiev
hello there Rob those are certainly some
serious allegations being made by the
Ukrainian president what more can you
tell us
yeah These Warnings are certainly a very
specific and with a lot of the details
being provided by Vladimir zielinski
himself as some of it in conversations
phone conversations he's had on Tuesday
one of them with Emmanuel macron of
France where he's accused the Russians
of dangerous provocations with regard to
uh zaparesia and in his nightly uh
briefing giving more details about what
he says the Ukrainian intelligence
Services have detected that they have
been placing these objects possibly
explosives on these power units on the
roof of zapparesia with the uh Ukrainian
military here in Kiev giving further
details that what they say could be
planned by the Russians is some sort of
simulated Ukrainian artillery attack on
the zaparesia plant in some kind of they
claim a false flag operation by the
Russians whatever the truth of it um
zielinski has said that this is a new
evil being perpetrated by the Russians
also making reference to the attack on
the car of kadam several weeks ago the
destruction of that Dam that the
ukrainians blame on the Russians saying
that the fact that the world did not
take a tough stand against that has
emboldened he says the Russians to take
this latest action
um these claims the warnings the fears
about zapparesia have been going on for
weeks if not months but there has been
now a warning from the department at the
Ministry of Health here in Ukraine that
residents around zapparesia should be
prepared to be evacuated if they detect
some kind of a large radiological
incident Rob what evidence does Kiev
have to substantiate these latest claims
as with all of these things that there
is there is the claim but a lack of Hard
Evidence to back up the claim so it has
to be treated with a certain amount of
circumspection uh but according to
Ukrainian media at least they are saying
that Ukrainian intelligence Services
have access to Satellite photographs
that prove that these objects had been
placed on the roof of zapparesia the
Ukrainian authorities here have not
admitted that fact and certainly have
not presented a photographic satellite
evidence if they have it there is also
there's always an issue from the
security services point of view of
presenting your intelligence gathering
to the other side to show how you're
getting your intelligence but the the
fact that these details are quite
specific and also we had another claim a
couple of weeks ago again from the
ukrainians that the Russians were
planting mines on the cooling ponds that
provide cooling water to the reactors at
zapparesia there is a concern I think
that because of these uh the allegations
are becoming more specific from the
Russian side they're even giving dates
and timings it seems on when they claim
the ukrainians might be planning some
action there is a sense at least that
possibly things here are coming to a
head all right thanks so much for
bringing us up to speed Rob McBride in
Kiev Let's cross to Yulia shapovalova
now who joins us from Moscow hello there
Yulia Russia has separately made its own
claims about Ukraine planning an attack
on that plant what's Moscow saying
yes indeed a representative of Russia's
Ross energo atsum accused the Ukrainian
Army preparing a strike on the station
on Tuesday July the 4th uh renat kachar
the deputy General director of the
Rosenberg atom Corporation said that
Ukraine would try to attack these
Apparition nuclear power plant on the
night of July the 5th with Precision
weapons and kamikazitros he said that
Ukraine intended to hit this station
with a missile with a radioactive
Warhead luckily that hasn't happened as
we see also according to the Russian
side on the night of July the 4th
Ukraine disconnected these operation
nuclear plant from the main external
power supply which obviously supplied
electricity to the station so this
station had to work using a backup line
and later the station's director Yuri
chernichuk reported that the power of
Supply was actually restored and since
then as when understand the station has
been working normally while the day
before yesterday before the reports
about The disconnection of the station
from the power supply the IAA actually
reported that this approach nuclear
power plant was reconnected to one of
the six spare transmission lines to
provide external electricity needed for
reactor Cooling and other critical
security functions uh well apart from
that we're still here not very loud
opinions here that Russia May seize the
zaprogin nuclear power plant station to
Ukraine because it's not part of the
land Corridor to Crimea which rushes so
fiercely fighting for so basically
that's the latest from Moscow all right
thanks so much Julia shapovalova in
Moscow thank you